I had a homie this happened to him he  hooked up with this girl right really  hot and then later he finds out this  girl was actually a trans she was a guy  before but never told him but what do  you mean hook up like they [ __ ] he was  embarrassed to talk about it he was  angry about it she came at him like  you're being transphobic for getting  bothered by it my thing is how would you  feel my question is did he come yes he  came then what is he complaining about  yeah exactly the fact that he wasn't  if I'm going in for a hookup and I got  what I wanted and it was great who  [ __ ] cares but what if his thing is  like I don't like trans girls that's him  being transphobic but why is it  translated that's what you like she  don't have to tell him if he busted or  not if he never knew that's it I used to  be a man like that's gonna [ __ ] a dude  up in today's time if you were at the  club and you met a shorty would you like  them to tell you if I had no idea  then  then